oi boa tarde como é que está a fazer uma
pequena referência ao tema proposto ou
nada para mim é sempre assustador e
esperar 30 gente falar para uma
audiência agora menos que mas continua a
ser quando foi convidado para estar aqui
sobre do tema decidi arriscar e aceitar
o convite pois estas experiências fazem
vencer este dinheiro e eu com 54 anos
acho que não preciso ir embora me custo
muita que estou e sinto muito honrado
com este convite e agora umas penas
altas sobre mim e apenas aquelas que eu
acho que são visíveis e determinantes os
meu trabalho comer oposto da terra aqui
ter postado por já já foi pedido
considera uma pessoa organizada e
metódica equilibrada arrumada essa
última característica muito próximos que
era obsessivo compulsivo que é um
problema para ter vindo comigo liga a
minha mulher também então
o reservado e com grande cidade de
momentos solitários o que venho aqui
partilhar não tem a ver com meu percurso
profissional igual já embora as ligações
mas sim com o meu passa-tempo preferido
e que nos últimos sete anos ocupou
grande parte da minha vida que é
fotografia e o instagram está
relacionado nos trato vir aqui ensinar
ninguém hoje disso que acho que não sei
pouco mas expor o que fiz e o que ainda
passo e mostrará a minha bolsa
é a minha relação com os terapia começou
na adolescência mais ou menos e vamos
nessa altura tentará fazer algumas
coisas diferentes mas que não ter
grandes alimenta até 2012 neste ano com
o digital e com o registro no instagram
tudo mudou comecei a partilhar aí o que
atrapalhando que o meu telemóvel de
forma despreocupada e regular e passados
cerca dois se atualizar no sentido que
idade devo ir na fotografia tecnicamente
entre uma câmera e fui se partilhado
o que começaram a surgir algumas reações
positivas e motivadora do que mostrar o
corte quase quase obsessiva até os dias
de hoje como o telemóvel e por isso nos
últimos cinco últimos quando quando
necessita para com câmera de noventa e
nove porcento das terapias que aparecem
na minha página no termos instagram
oferecido português na minha praia são
feitas com câmeras de marcas e modelos e
cores diferentes como é que fotográfico
não aumente realmente não é sempre no
manual onde quanto conseguir controlar
tudo no início custou-me um bocado
adaptar mas depois nos habituar mas acho
que ninguém volta automático novamente
os duas câmeras uma mais pequena e
discreta que é ideal para para piso de
volta eu gosto de fazer e outra que
posso mudar as lentes também é especial
com a sofia de da prefeitura
e é quase sempre um ato solitário
distintivo e rápido ou seja nunca perco
muito tempo assim o que é que vou
preparar nem nem perto muito tempo
editar por não considerar um
perfeccionista e o que sinto quando te
bravo talvez quando sinto mais inspirado
eu digo também feliz porque são momentos
em que eu peço mostrar do mundo é uma
profunda é mesmo uma profunda sensação
de estar realizado sereno e ao mesmo
tempo também de extra no que o erro é
o que é que esquece agora o que vou aqui
partilhar não tem a ver com este
percurso no no instagram esta é a
primeira foto
e como é que eu cheguei aqui eu isso é
um bocado confuso mas eu acho que tem
haver um bocado com sorte digo sorte que
acho que tive sorte consegui ficar em
mim está muito cativo a ajuda de muita
gente que motivou e que estava o meu
trabalho vou ensinar uma qualidade ea
expectativa de sorte consegui
identificar e minha aula que eu tinha um
jeito de fazer e depois fui trabalhando
e com compaixão e pronto e as aqui um
bocado digo eu console e acho que o
maior parte das pessoas também consegue
atacar os outros poderá fazer alguma
coisa que tive sempre tenho sorte depois
tem que trabalhar muito e não descobrir
continuar a procurar e esperar acho que
também chegaram a aqui a primeira foto
e eu quero vou começar a passar esta
atualização costumo só umas imagens são
muitas as pessoas especiais que vai
forma raiva que me dá sempre foi muitas
portas e o teu pai limitado e já está em
três minutos e eu acho que a minha foto
fala mais com as minhas palavras mas
durante esta isso é esse número a
curiosidade foi a primeira falta foi
2012 aqui agora vou passar alguns temas
recorrentes que há vários meses o ferro
e das criaturas para os mais que
aparecem mais os títulos em inglês tem a
ver com nesse caso não tem haver
contactos no instagram outro achar ficar
melhor aqui até que o telemóvel foi foi
na escola comissões das comissárias
perfeitas com o telemóvel cemitério no
15 e a praça praça da madonna tu perde
cá eu mostrei device não quando eu
trocava com o telemóvel usar os filtros
do instagram e assim carregado quantas
horas não é esses isto
o lado a preto e branco foi tirada no
hospital quantos anos em mirandela e
outra na numa caixa multibanco da cama
com aqueles fios que que já nos aquilo
não os temas mais recorrentes no que eu
vou passar aqui alguns 30 para pia de
rua a primeira foto foi tirada no lugar
na correia dos sítios mais difícil do
que ter feito por que ao fim de dez
minutos aquilo que a dor é insuportável
não sei ficar pingar e também eles não
gostam de ser fácil alguns problemas com
isso outro sorteio do outro lado foi um
sofia que dispôs uma exposição que é foi
tirada a vila praia de âncora que eu
sinto que eu gosto muito de ir e temos
de ser boa no verão tem muito assunto
para a curada que também é um sítio que
o sol o torcedor gosta dele tem muitas
pessoas peculiares arquitetura também as
casas tem aqueles azulejos pronto
encontra o centenário
bom então este fotografias fotografia do
lado foi um casal neste percebi durante
algum tempo aqui em guimarães até achei
que tinha que ele está motivo iguais nas
propostas é que tu precisava a ideia de
união porque por é a mesma e vieram
sempre agarradinhos um outro pronto e
isso é na praça oliveira ver ser
retirado em sangai que alguém me disse
não podia como é que eu não metros
terapias que eu faça parece uma pessoa
como é que eu enxerguei culto tensão é
conseguir tirar fotografia só uma pessoa
aqui o fluminense pessoas na rua mas ele
vai estar mais de madrugada e para tirar
fotografias outra foi em nova york este
ano e foi aquele aquele senhor o rapaz
para mandar textão para bar ou figura
para o funcionário atrás e está
atrapalhando e tive a sorte de passar
esta rapariga e porque quando seus
professores aqui pronto criado aqui é
uma dinâmica e movimento e obter
floresta
e esta prima esta primeira e o que foi
tirado rádio portugal deste ano eu
quando era milksa seis anos e ao vivo
rádios portugal e mais perto deles e
deixei de poder te atender esse horário
para mim e fui ajudar na papo ou queria
tá lá no 35 anos e fiquei em esta
exposição bocado não para ficar nenhum
só pra pessoas eu ver a cabra a minha
câmera discreta e pequena e ninguém
operador provar isso é uma delas a outra
foi tirada também e nova york é uma
fotografia sente e alguém disse que esta
esta terapia de fazer lembrar uma capa
do álbum do pink floyd the hospital não
se esqueçam também de ser feio que o
senhor várias formas só somos ser feito
diferente porque não me aturas preto
respeita as pessoas podem esteja com uma
tábua do instagram ou táxi logo ele para
mim no meu perfil para espalhar a este o
buraco mais é o que parece mais que
é capaz de ver a isto que aparece mais
tem a ver com o edifício leonardo sítio
que aparece uma pessoa ou uma silhueta
mas não o nome desse tipo de pequenas a
pessoa que eu do lado das pontes do
porto eu tive sorte ou não no porto a
fugires assim quando veio isso em paz
sete e meio até amanhã quando faltava
nascer e foi só esperar um pouco passar
se alguém na ponte e passou lá aquele
passou aquele senhor o senhor acho que
pronto e a única parece aquelas prontos
e tenho tenha gostado da primeira ponte
a segunda não sei se tiver terceira
simples ótimo capa
e esta estas duas foram captadas no
espinho outra em na póvoa e com dois
filhos estava a apanhar sol de inverno o
primeiro do preto e branco o tamanho
perfeito de até diferente perfeito que
ele teve a limpar 10 minutos e o senhor
começou a atenção além da posição dele
gostar assim foi o quarto dele as cores
o amarelo com vermelho com o azul do céu
com tudo aquilo que combinava ali um
para mim um cenário respeito a posição
dele a primeira falta do raio foi criado
este ano nas alturas que foi convidado
por fugir para fazermos as coisas provar
e isso é inocente demais eu subir uma
escada pela lá tive reparando aquele
rasgo e como a câmera permite este
contraste muito grande entre de luz e
sombra e eu pedi uma amiga também foi
conosco ela colocar lá na naquela
posição tá de uma profissional
eu não tava ali ninguém passar mas
pronto teve outro lado em nova york lá
no edifício da estação perto do brasil
esperei finalmente é melhor apanhar
alguém a última aula com chapéu para
legal novamente o que será que muitos
velhinhos porque é o bengala leva os
réus neste caso pois estava conhecia
esperamos um bocadinho e consegui
apanhar um senhor feito uma mala com
guarda-chuva e com o chapéu lá mais e
isso o que ele tinha da estação também
arquitetura pronto é o tempo que eu
naturalmente fotográfico muito a
primeira falta ali na póvoa da fonte
acima ela acho que ela ser qualquer
pessoa que passasse alguém tirava porque
ele é tão escandaloso edifício com três
metros e pronto é fácil essa aqui é do
estado de braga e a única porque tem de
água que não tem o cão
o que também foi um convite para te
mostrar o estádio tão difícil que eu
gosto muito que é do souto moura já foi
alguns anos para a 56 tirei várias esta
retirada aqui pouco tempo depois do
edifício está terminado eu sabia qo que
é ciclo dispenso tinha um por baixo o
vidro tanto lá tenho o pavimento tava lá
sentar e para que estava na vasilha
ciclista deixei o passar fotografei e
depois pensar ouvirá porque ao contrário
tanto aqui ela não está no a tirei outro
lado é multiuso estes são chamados de
loops 11 shanghai hotel em nova york o
mangá não se tem o objetivo do outro sei
que é do bardock no meu nos arquitetos
aqui são surpresas recentes dos obras
que nós fizemos que é o parque da
caldeira ó
e nesse caso aqui eu tive que usar uma
lente grande angular para apanhar as
escadas todas e aquilo circos e ele tem
uma escola que nós fizemos no saco
a arquitetura no também gosto muito de
ter vários alto petrolina claro sem
autor gosto mesmo muito preparo ponha a
peste que não a composição mas para mim
isto está composto pronto apesar estás
hornet está composto por mim para mim
pronto este passados que aparece e
fachadas com um elemento ser relação ao
que os outros aparentemente nos permitem
no caso está começou a atenção dos
azulejos diferentes cada uma das presas
pelo pagamento também um esse tipo essas
cada também pronto para mim és tu gosto
de fazer esse tipo de terapia
e essas são mais banais outra outro é
aquele lá também acho que é tomar o
outro difícil qualquer pessoa passa ali
e aquilo chamou a atenção e pronto
recortar o frente o lado
a escrever como ataque que o próximo
espaço olhos esta estou agora
superficiais e menos começou a surgir
muito no instagram e eu pronto tenho
feito mesmo a primeira é uma das minhas
favoritas foi tirada no gana tanto pelos
pula-pula senhora pela sombra dela na
parede outro foi baseado no mercado do
bolhão
é a primeira da madeira a outra colocar
aqui apenas pela relação que tem das
linhas cor laranja do muro com a
camisola da senhora quer exatamente a
mesma cor outros tipos tiver essas aqui
o às vezes eu tirar fotografia e nem não
for ela das combinações só quando chegar
à casa em que sorte pronto e nesse caso
neste caso não foi bem assim mas foi
qual isto é outro pessoa muitos temas
por isso é que são muitas pessoas que eu
não é tudo ou nada detalhes a composição
é uma afastar é uma casa no centro
histórico outro teste embasam a guarda
do estado do vitória um aguardo por lá
e são mais tarde teve a composição
o sombras isto o telemóvel não consigo
fazer tipografia não sei usar a câmera e
como deu o que eu tinha também não agora
aqui com que a confirmar que uso
assentou muitos contrastes entre luz e
sombra não é que a outra a outra está
aqui não erp pronto o senhor estava a
conversar eu parei no segundo troquei o
senhor mas esse conta o do outro lado o
contraste de claro-escuro gosto muito de
fazer o estas aqui do lado direito essa
foi criada aqui em guimarães
o adãozinho eta também é é um tema que o
seu pai há um ano é que me fez travar é
deixar passar uma pessoa na zona de
sombra e a parte de trás tá ali me nada
aparece assim outra só e dá um filme
interessante ou até das escolas das
taipas de três em paisagem ou não é um
tema que eu não me sinto muito a vontade
aí no espaço muito mas também o passo
por que que me deu o procurar tudo
e no caso a primeira aquela ali foi no
enquanto nós tivemos em viana pois como
usar lavar o nome do outro lado foi
tirada no pinhal de leiria é que está a
pessoa tempo
eu já tinha alegria até o fim seca do no
porto arte solitárias também gosto muito
de gravar cenas urbanas foi o médico
tudo que está com que a pessoa que já
são algumas antigas esse nada então já
pouco faço isso fazer quando a minha
mulher me acompanha há agora me
acompanha no perfil não tem paciência e
a minha filha também não gosta de ser
fotografada com ciúmes quando ela me
acompanhava eu fazia algumas pedia para
ela se colocar algumas posições ou
alguns tipos para dar escalar o
exercício ao espaço aquela da fundação
estampada não é minha filha e disso a
isso é a melhor parte da minha
atualização acho que eu e aqui vocês vão
ficar aqui essa parte de trava os seus
vestidinho cadinho
bom e aquela original e essa é que ficou
tanto tempo fotografo e às vezes me
preocupo poucos tá volta que foi pego no
programa leite rolo e corte no apagar
corte e expressivos que ficou assim e
aciona pode ser aquelas escadas coloquei
no da regra dos terços que aprontou
novamente os olhos e aciona não tenho
vários e direito lindas não sabe aquela
terapia assim igual nada aqui pronto
próximo ao mercadinho isso também
e essa também tinha muito atrás da volta
e frente se o youtube e ficou só a peste
que a senhora fica pescar o céu é muito
estranho isso sabe parece que o céu que
ela vai cair esta foi não sei o que eu
tirei nos piscinas ao lado estado de
braga e que já tem os anos não tinha
cama para profissionario e depois tive
aproximar
e ninguém aquela terapia assim vale nada
depois editando deu isto que eu acho que
pronto tem alguma qualidade e se eu
podia aquele amigo portugueses outra
também
é mas almeida prof as favoritas que
algumas raças tomate aquelas podia o seu
paredes pneus que se fosse obrigada a
fotografia e assim esta mosteiro de
tibães do quando entrei na sala e as
cadeiras assim sua família né os pais
pai e mãe os filhos a
e aos favoritos
o que era um cemitério que entrei por
acaso e a fera nas horas
e aí
em alguma das cabritas esta foi um dia
que já estava a virilha nenhum caso
animado que me disse assim nada especial
e quando já havia ficar quando espera
com este cenário a permitem tu tem a
ruína tenho o carro 20 se tem a
brasileiro depois daquele tudo pronto
para mim esta é este tipo de competições
que funcionam bem e fez aqui agora não
interessa tanto falar com trabalhos por
às vezes foi convidado para fazer e fiz
real ao modelo que tem a ver com o
instagram mas não sou influências e
influenciador faço porque gosto desse
apenas e não tente forçar ninguém com o
meu trabalho apenas partilhar a gente e
espero que tenham gostado ou se era mais
à frente a última fotografia que foi a
por foi o que foi feita no no
instrumento que eu tive a hora
matosinhos e convidados foi um
instrumento internacional para promover
a câmara de matosinhos e
o face é o último é que é 1974 tenho
muita 1934-8 na minha padre pronto quem
quiser apreciar mais um bocado no meu
trabalho pode lá e muito obrigado a